der Menschen in der Schweiz
Angehörige -
.
* Babybrabbeln *
Vater sein, ein Riesenglück.
Voller Liebe, voller Anstrengung.
Für dieses Wesen sorge ich, ein Leben
lang. Doch sorgt es auch für mich?
Im Kreislauf von Geburt und Tod
kommt der Tag,
an dem ich alt sein werde. Und dann?
Ab Mitte 40
unterstützt mehr als die Hälfte
der Menschen in der Schweiz
Angehörige -
am häufigsten die Eltern.
Die Mehrheit davon sind Frauen.
Ich beginne die Suche nach Kindern,
die sich mit dieser sehr persönlichen
Frage der Verantwortung beschäftigen
und erlebe, wie sie sich mit Sorge
und Fürsorge um ihre Eltern kümmern.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
(Navigationsgerät)
Dem Strassenverlauf 1,5 km folgen.
Gery Huber fährt regelmässig
von ihrem Wohnort im Kanton Solothurn
nach Zürich.
Vor Kurzem hatte ihr 95-jähriger
Vater eine schwere Hüftarthrose.
* Bedrückende Klänge *
Es wurde immer schlimmer.
Er hatte extreme Schmerzen,
konnte kaum mehr aufstehen.
Ihr Vater musste ins Spital,
wurde notfallmässig operiert.
Während der Operation
hat man einen Infekt entdeckt.
Er hatte einen Rieseninfekt.
Ich fragte,
wie lange das noch gegangen wäre.
Es wären nur ein paar Tage gewesen.
Das ist eine explosive Sache.
Mit Bakterien -
das verschlimmert sich rasant,
dann wäre er gestorben.
Er ist seit einer Woche im Spital.
Morgen wird er operiert.
Es ist besser geworden mit dem Keim.
Jetzt versucht man,
morgen das Hüftgelenk einzusetzen.
Hallo.
Im ersten Moment
hatte ich ein schlechtes Gewissen.
Ich fragte mich, ob ich sein Leben
oder sein Leiden verlängert habe.
Mir ging es immer
um die Lebensqualität.
Sind Sie froh,
dass Sie operiert werden,
ein künstliches Hüftgelenk bekommen?
Ja, wir werden sehen,
was dabei herauskommt.
Ich lasse mich überraschen.
Viel mehr kann man nicht machen.
Ich kann ja nicht gehen,
ohne dass jemand Grüezi sagt.
Grüezi.
- Grüezi.
Oh, störe ich?
Macht nichts, kommen Sie nur.
Sind Sie vom Fernsehen?
Wir drehen einen Dokumentarfilm.
Herr Huber
ist einer der Protagonisten.
Herr Dora.
Okay.
- Sie sind Herr ...
Dora ist mein Name.
Hat Herr Keller Sie angerufen?
Herr Keller?
- Der Anästhesist.
Ja, also
gleich nach der ersten Operation.
Aber jetzt noch nicht.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob er heute angerufen hat.
Er ist der Meinung,
man soll die Operation nicht machen.
Nicht?
- Nein.
Er möchte
eine sechswöchige Pause machen.
Ah.
- Die Risiken seien zu hoch.
Ja.
Der Anästhesist kann am besten
die Risiken des Alters abschätzen.
Ich möchte mich nicht
gegen ihn stellen.
Hm-m.
- Die Devise war ...
... wenn es geht,
so schnell wie möglich.
Damit die Zeit,
in der er nicht mobil ist, kurz ist.
Aber der Anästhesist meint,
die Risiken seien zu hoch.
Ja.
- Und zwar erheblich hoch.
Sogar.
- Er würde sie nicht machen.
Und in sechs Wochen
bestehen die Risiken nicht mehr?
Ja. Aber die Gefahr besteht, dass er
in diesen Wochen schwächer wird,
weil er immer im Bett liegt.
Das wäre nicht gut.
Das heisst,
in der Zwischenzeit muss er ...
... irgendwo sein,
wo man sich um ihn kümmert,
damit er bei Kräften bleibt.
Gut, neue Situation. Ganz neu.
Wenn ich 20 Jahre jünger wäre,
würde es schneller gehen.
(Arzt) Ja, das ist so.
Es geht ihm nicht schlecht.
Nein. Und ich hätte es spontan
auch gemacht.
Aber ich habe die Sicht des
Orthopäden und sehe nur das Gehen.
Hast du verstanden, um was es geht?
Ja, ja, schon.
Eben. Es geht halt länger,
als man denkt.
Ja.
Ja, das ist ein Hammer.
Ich habe mich für ihn gefreut.
Ich habe gehofft,
dass es bergauf geht.
Und dass er die Kräfte,
die er noch hat,
für die Heilung nutzen könnte.
Jetzt ist es eine neue Situation.
Wir werden so weiterfahren,
wie es dann eben kommt.
Und so wie sie es uns empfehlen.
Unsere Aufgabe ist es,
zu unterstützen
und zu schauen, dass alles läuft.
Und ihn sicher auch moralisch
etwas auf der Höhe halten.
Ich denke, dieser Ansatz
kann auch zur Heilung beitragen.
Ich habe eine gute Jungmannschaft,
die zusammenhält.
Das ist wichtig.
Nicht wahr?
- Ja, ja.
Auch die Enkel ...
- Wir sind vor Ort.
Er ist auch ein guter Vater.
- Sicher, Stammhalter.
Vielen Dank für alles.
Hans Huber bleibt die nächste Nacht
in der Klinik.
Wie es dann weitergeht, ist offen.
Als ich beginne, mich mit dem Thema
dieses Films zu beschäftigen,
kommt sie mir als Erstes in den Sinn:
Anny.
Seit bald 70 Jahren
wohnt sie an "ihrer" Möhrlistrasse,
im Kreis 6 in Zürich.
Über ein Jahrzehnt
haben wir im gleichen Haus gewohnt.
Ich dachte immer: Wenn ich mal
alt bin, möchte ich so sein wie sie.
So.
Wie viele Jahre
hast du in diesem Haus gewohnt?
65. 65 Jahre.
Hier war mein Briefkasten.
Ihr Mann Guido
ist vor zehn Jahren gestorben.
Mit ihm hat sie vier Kinder
grossgezogen. Regula ist die Älteste.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
sie sei dort allein.
Und wenn irgendwann etwas ist,
ist sie nicht diejenige,
die im ganzen Haus herumgeht,
klingelt und um Hilfe bittet.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
sie müsse an einen Ort,
an dem sie mehr unter Leuten sei.
Am anderen Ende der Möhrlistrasse
hat die 89-Jährige
vor Kurzem
eine Alterswohnung bezogen.
Wir haben zusammen
die Wohnung besichtigt.
Wir kamen rein und sagten:
"Wow! Das ist es."
Das war genau das,
was sie sich vorgestellt hatte.
Sie hat sofort zugesagt.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich bin kein Putzteufel.
Manchmal habe ich einfach nur
mit dem Ärmel darübergestrichen.
Nein, nein.
Aber hier
ist es schon ab und zu nötig.
Ich begleite Gery Huber vom Spital
in die Wohnung ihres Vaters.
Frau Huber, hat Ihr Vater
hier selbstständig gewohnt?
Ja, bis er ins Spital musste,
lebte er
in dieser Zweieinhalbzimmerwohnung.
Sie haben ihn unterstützt?
Und die Spitex, die wir aber erst
seit einem Monat beigezogen haben.
Vorher machte er
den Haushalt selbst.
Ich komme jede Woche
einen ganzen Tag hierher.
Und meine Brüder unterstützen mich,
das ist klar.
Sie kommen Samstag und Sonntag
vorbei.
Hier ist Mama.
Ich sage ihr jeweils Hoi.
Sie ist vor einem Jahr gestorben,
darum ist Vater seither hier allein.
Und so hat sich
die Situation ergeben.
Wir mussten handeln.
Sie kam ins Pflegeheim,
ganz unverhofft.
Das war der Grund, warum wir
Geschwister zusammengekommen sind
und die Situation von Vater
angeschaut haben.
Ja.
Im Gespräch mit meinen
beiden Brüdern haben wir abgemacht,
dass derjenige, der etwas tut,
dafür entschädigt wird.
Das ist ein heikler Punkt
und wird zu wenig ...
Es wird zu wenig diskutiert.
Es geht nicht um Abzocke und darum,
sich daran zu bereichern.
Es geht darum, dass man
für die Spesen etwas bekommt.
Und wer einen Beitrag leisten kann,
bekommt eine Entschädigung dafür.
Vater zahlt uns unsere Spesen.
Frau Huber,
beziehen Sie das Bett ihres Vaters
in der Hoffnung,
dass er nach Hause kommt?
Ja, das wäre schön.
Ich finde: Bereit ist bereit.
Ich habe noch lange das Bett
meiner Mutter bereit gemacht,
in der Hoffnung.
Es ist spannend.
Seit Mutter gestorben ist,
hat es Platz für eine neue Beziehung
zu meinen Vater.
Ich konnte mir vorher
nicht vorstellen,
dass ich mit ihm
20 Min. telefonieren kann.
Ich habe ihn neu entdeckt,
und das ist eine Chance.
Ich finde das sehr schön.
Jetzt warte ich
auf den Anruf aus dem Spital,
wie es weitergeht.
Es gibt dort eine Sozialstelle,
die das koordiniert,
ein Pflegheim, die Reha.
Dann hoffe ich,
es ist nicht zu weit entfernt,
damit ich ihn besuchen kann.
Und dass es bald losgeht.
Mit Erstaunen erfahre ich:
Betagte Menschen, die vorübergehend
in ein Pflegeheim kommen,
können nicht selten
wieder nach Hause.
Am Ende dieser Strasse
finde ich eine solche Geschichte -
eine voller Wunder,
Freude und Traurigkeit.
(Mann) Guten Tag.
So, ihr seid vom Fernsehen.
Jawohl.
Ein Buchstabe fehlt noch.
S, und dann kommt
der fehlende Buchstabe, A, C, E.
Sonst habe ich alles.
Das ist das letzte.
Machen Sie das jeden Tag?
- Jeden Tag, das ist mir wichtig.
Ja.
- Warum ist Ihnen das wichtig?
Ja, um ... daran zu denken.
Es ist auch bildend. Ja, ja.
Ja, ja.
Ich lerne einen offenen,
weltgewandten Menschen kennen.
Willi Burkart, 88,
war 26 Jahre lang Lehrer
und ist, Zeit seines Lebens,
Künstler.
Seit vielen Jahren
lebt er getrennt von seiner Frau.
Hoi, Papa.
- Sali, Theres.
Wie geht's?
- Ja, danke.
Grüezi.
- Sie sind immer noch da.
Hoi, Papa.
Ist es gut gegangen?
- Ja, ja.
Schön.
Ich habe Essen mitgebracht.
Oh, vielen Dank.
Ich habe etwas bereit gemacht.
Hast du heute schon etwas gegessen?
- Nein, noch nicht.
Ich hatte etwas Gemüse.
- Sonst noch nichts?
Im Januar 2017
hatte er einen Schlaganfall.
Er ist zu Hause im Flur
in eine Tür gefallen.
Hier ist es passiert.
Ich bin ins Fenster gefallen.
Das Fenster ist kaputtgegangen.
Irgendjemand
hat es für mich geflickt. Jawohl.
Die Scheibe ist kaputtgegangen.
Alles war voller Scherben.
Er hat versucht, sich aufzuziehen.
Das hat nicht funktioniert.
Er hat aber daran gedacht,
den Knopf zu drücken.
Er wurde ins Spital
nach Baden gebracht.
Er hat nichts mehr verstanden.
Später hat es geheissen,
Reha ginge nicht,
Er komme nach Königsfelden, weil er
immer noch sehr verwirrt war.
Dort wurde er mit den Medikamenten
besser eingestellt.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Er hat darauf hingearbeitet,
wieder nach Hause zu kommen.
Es kam immer besser.
Man sah das auch
an den Kreuzworträtseln.
Er konnte die Kreuzworträtsel
wieder besser ausfüllen.
So ging das Jahr vorüber,
bis es Januar 2018 wurde,
und er sagte, dass er wieder nach
Hause wolle, er sei wieder fit.
Dann haben wir langsam angefangen
zu planen.
Es ist nicht selbstverständlich,
dass er wieder so gesund wurde.
Aber das ist toll.
Es ist auch sein Wille.
Ich sprach auch noch davon,
Dinge zu schätzen.
Ich schätze es an ihm,
dass er einen starken Willen hat,
etwas zu erreichen.
Vorher hat er
das Essen selber gemacht.
Leider musste er vor zwei Wochen
alle Zähne ziehen lassen.
Jetzt ist es etwas schwierig
mit dem Kochen.
Ihm fehlen die Ideen,
darum habe ich etwas vorbereitet.
Ich glaube, er geniesst es,
dass ich ihm etwas vorbereite.
Sobald er wieder essen kann,
muss er auch wieder selber kochen.
Jetzt ist gut geschüttelt.
Hallo.
- Hallo, hallo.
Grüezi.
- Grüezi. Hoi.
So, habt ihr es geschafft?
Ihr habt mich
beim Zeitungslesen gestört.
Ich lese gleich noch ein bisschen.
- Dann bist du mir im Weg.
Hier?
- Ja.
Sie hat sich für die Alterswohnung
zu interessieren begonnen,
kurz nachdem Paps gestorben ist.
Sie hat sich angemeldet.
Dann dauerte es aber
noch sieben Jahre,
bis sie einen Platz erhalten hat.
Sie hat ihre Wünsche angebracht,
sie wollte im Quartier bleiben,
an der Möhrlistrasse bleiben.
Sie wollte im ersten Stock bleiben
und einen Balkon zur Strasse haben.
Regula,
wie unterstützt du deine Mutter?
Ich helfe so weit wie möglich
im Haushalt.
Ich staubsauge,
wische ab und zu den Boden ...
Ich übernehme die groben Arbeiten.
Anny, lässt du dir von Regula helfen?
Ähm, ja, gerne.
V.a. bei den Dingen,
die ich nicht gerne mache.
Du staubsaugst nicht gerne?
- Nein.
Das hat immer Guido gemacht,
das kannst du dir ja vorstellen.
Und so um die Dinge herum ...
Wenn alles nur geradeaus wäre
und man die Sachen
nicht hin- und herschieben müsste,
wäre es mir noch egal.
Aber um die Ecken herum ...
Sie kommt furchtbar gerne.
Wir sind so etwas wie Freundinnen.
Jede hat ihr eigenes Leben.
Sie ist sehr eigenständig.
Sie organisiert ihr Leben selber.
Wenn ich den ganzen Tag Action habe,
habe ich keine Zeit, müde zu werden.
Wenn ich an einem Tag
mal nur auf dem Sofa und so ...
... dann bin ich müde.
Wenn Regula sagt:
"Mach doch weniger!"
Kannst du das gut annehmen?
- Ja, ja, ja.
Ich kann alles gut annehmen.
Und umsetzen?
Du ... Kommt darauf an, was.
Wir sagten schon oft: Hörgeräte.
Je mehr wir sagten ...
Eines Tages sagte ich,
ich sage nichts mehr.
Dann hatte sie diesen Vorfall,
eine Entzündung,
worauf sie zum Ohrenarzt ging.
Dann ging das los,
und jetzt hat sie ein Hörgerät.
Das ist tipptopp.
Sie kann sich überall
wieder beteiligen, mitreden.
Ich möchte einfach,
dass es ihr gut geht.
Und dass ihr ...
... grössere Dinge,
Unannehmlichkeiten erspart bleiben,
bzw. sie das nicht machen muss.
Und dass sie das Leben nun,
nachdem sie so viel gearbeitet
und für andere getan hat,
geniessen kann.
* Sanfte Streichklänge *
Vier Wochen, nachdem die OP
ihres Vaters verschoben wurde,
treffe ich Gery Huber wieder.
Der 95-Jährige ist zur Rehabilitation
in einer Privatklinik.
Hier wird er intensiv mobilisiert.
Er bekommt intensiv Physiotherapie.
Gleichzeitig bekommt er
eine Antibiotikatherapie,
damit der Keim weggeht.
Das dauert noch bis 14. Januar.
Dann sollte er 14 Tage ohne
Medikamente keinen Keim mehr machen,
bzw. keinen Infekt machen.
Dann wird man sehen,
was man nachher machen kann.
Hoi.
- Geht's dir gut?
Ja, ja.
- Hoi.
Geht's?
Schön.
So.
Grüezi, Herr Huber.
- Grüezi, Herr ... - Heusser.
Erinnern Sie sich?
- Auch schon gesehen. - Genau.
Papi, ich bringe dich an den Tisch,
ich habe Post mitgebracht.
So können wir das
zusammen anschauen.
Kannst du selber?
Kannst du selber zum Tisch hin?
Einigermassen.
Schau her. Gut.
Die Physio zeigt ihre Wirkung.
Ist gut?
- Ja, ja.
Hans Huber lebt im Moment
ohne linkes Hüftgelenk.
So.
Jetzt machen wir das schön langsam.
Wie immer.
Und Ferse, Spitze, Ferse, Spitze.
Und noch einmal.
Und wieder lösen.
Genau.
Solange er die Motivation hat,
hat er auch Lebenswille und Freude.
Darum gehen wir diesen Weg.
Und jetzt ... hoch, hoch, hoch.
Und rechts und links.
Noch einmal ganz locker, Herr Huber.
Spannt das am Rist?
Hans Huber
kennt das Gesundheitsweisen.
Er war bis zu seiner Pension
Technischer Assistent
am Unispital Zürich.
Ich glaube, du könntest das besser.
Sie wollen einfach
kein Risiko eingehen.
Wenn irgendetwas
nicht sauber ist ...
Aber jetzt stehen die Chancen
nicht schlecht,
dass man operieren könnte.
Ich brauche ein neues Hüftgelenk.
Dann muss man schauen,
ob es funktioniert.
Gibt es Alternativen, Frau Huber?
Wenn es mit dem Hüftgelenk
nicht funktioniert,
ist er - krass gesagt - Invalide.
Er würde dann wohl
ins Bachwiesen kommen.
Ins Pflegeheim
in der Nähe seines Wohnorts.
Dann würde er dort bleiben.
Es kommt darauf an,
wie das Laufen geht.
Ja, aber ohne Hüftgelenk
kannst du nicht gehen.
Nein, das nicht.
Für das Hüftgelenk
braucht es eine Operation.
Das ist nun eben ... ja ...
die Frage, ob es funktioniert.
Das muss der Professor
der Schulthess-Klinik entscheiden.
Er muss operieren.
- Genau.
* Dumpfe Bassklänge *
* Helle, langsame Klänge *
Man wollte mir
einen Treppenlift geben,
aber ich möchte lieber
Treppen steigen.
* Helle, langsame Klänge *
So. Jetzt.
Mittags fahre ich zur Kartbahn.
Ich muss unter die Leute,
das ist mir ... wie Medizin.
Ich brauche die Ausstrahlung,
die Aura der Menschen.
Das ist mir wichtig.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
Verantwortung übernommen zu haben,
dadurch, dass ich gesagt habe,
er dürfe wieder nach Hause.
Wieso wollten Sie,
dass er nach Hause kommt?
Ich wollte ihm
seinen Wunsch erfüllen.
Er hat so sehr darauf hingearbeitet.
Der zweite Grund
sind auch die Kosten.
Im Altersheim ist sein Vermögen
immer geringer geworden.
Und ...
Er brauchte die Betreuung dort
nicht mehr im gleichen Ausmass.
Wir sprachen auch
mit den Leuten vom Altersheim.
Sie sagten auch,
dass wir es versuchen sollen.
* Beschwingte Streichmusik *
Die Operation bei Hans Huber
ist geglückt.
Er hat jetzt
ein künstliches Hüftgelenk.
(Frau) Wir machen eine Übung
an der Treppe. Geht es Ihnen?
Ja, ich probiere es.
Nehmen Sie mal die erste Stufe
mit dem rechten Bein.
Genau. Möchten Sie wieder runter
oder gehen Sie die Treppe hoch?
Dann machen wir die ganze.
Es ist verrückt, dass Ihr Vater
wieder Treppen steigt, oder?
Ja, extrem.
Ich sehe es auch zum ersten Mal.
Das ist sehr irreal.
Das ist wirklich ein Glück.
Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass es so schnell geht.
Und der Wille, den er hat.
Das ist es doch: sein Wille.
Das erstaunt mich immer wieder.
- Super.
Es war sein Wunsch,
den wir unterstützt haben.
Er hatte grosse Freude,
als er eine Hüfte bekommen hat.
Ich sagte:
"Macht, was ihr für möglich haltet."
Aber für den Professor
war es ein schwieriger Entscheid.
Ich bekam grosse Unterstützung
von meinen Kindern.
Das ist es in erster Linie.
Alle haben gut für mich gesorgt.
Das war unglaublich.
Kann man als Vater erwarten,
dass die Kinder das für einen machen?
Ich fand es nicht
selbstverständlich.
Es gibt viele Familien,
die zerstritten sind
und was weiss ich was.
Bei uns klappt es immer.
Wie viele Geschwister haben Sie?
Wir sind insgesamt vier.
Meine Schwester Gabi
ist die älteste.
Gabi übernahm v.a. die Rolle,
zu meinem Vater zu schauen.
Mit dem Ofen
hast du jetzt schön warm.
Ja, ja. Es ist angenehm.
- Tipptopp.
Gabi bekam am 1. Dezember vor
einem Jahr die Diagnose Lungenkrebs.
Ja.
Sie kann nicht mehr
zu meinem Vater schauen.
Darum habe ich das übernommen.
Du musst diesen Artikel
unbedingt ...
Ich lege ihn dir zur Seite.
"Mit Vollgas gegen Krebs".
-  Ah ja?
Ja.
Sorgen Sie sich um Ihre Tochter?
Ja, es gibt mir ...
Ich bete für sie.
Auf Portugiesisch.
Ave Maria, cheia de Graca,
o Senhor e convosco.
Bendita sois vos entre as mulheres
e bendito e o fruto do vosso ventre,
Jesus Christus.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Im Zentrum Bruder Klaus in Zürich
veranstaltet Anny seit 20 Jahren
Jass-Nachmittage. Unterstützt wird
sie vom Seelsorger Franz-Othmar.
Sonst geben wir noch Joghurt dazu.
Also Schnaps ist keiner drin.
Ich habe das Gefühl ...
- Ohne Schnaps wird reklamiert.
Nein, aber zu Heidelbeeren
passt nun wirklich kein Schnaps.
Ich bin dafür verantwortlich,
dass es etwas zu Essen gibt
und dass alle einen Sitzplatz haben.
* Verspielte Klänge *
Dani, ihr schneidet schon etliches
von meinem Geplapper raus, oder?
* Verspielte Klänge *
Oh, die sind immer widerspenstig.
Tschau, Anny. Es war gut.
- Das ist recht.
Alles Gute.
- Dir auch.
Tschau.
- Es war super heute.
Hast du alles selber gemacht?
- Ja.
* Verspielte Klänge *
So.
Theres erzählt mir,
sie sei fünf gewesen,
als ihr Vater
mit dem Aushub seines Hauses begann.
Im Gartenhäuschen nebenan
wohnt während der Sommermonate
ihr Bruder Beni.
Nach seiner Heirat
hat es ihn nach Indien verschlagen.
Wenn Beni weg ist,
lebt Willi allein hier -
mit seinen Lastern:
dem Rauchen und Trinken.
Pupupup.
Er sagte einmal, er werde 100.
(Verlegend lachend)
Wer weiss. Das könnte sein.
Was muss er machen,
damit er das erreicht?
Seinen Weg gehen, denke ich.
Es ist immer gut,
einen Weg zu haben.
Und schauen, dass er ...
also v.a. mit dem Alkohol ...
nicht zu viel trinkt.
Und sonst einfach gesund leben.
Und seinen Rhythmus.
Ich denke, das ist gut.
Wie ist die Situation
mit dem Alkohol?
Ich kann es nicht sagen.
Er hat eine Flasche dort stehen.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob er viel oder wenig trinkt.
Er entsorgt die Flaschen selber,
darum weiss ich es nicht.
Es ist nicht mein Leben.
Es ist sein Leben.
Er macht es sich.
Willi, Sie sagten mir, dass Sie
früher mehr getrunken hätten.
Und jetzt weniger?
- Ja, ja.
Das macht mir nichts aus.
Wie schaffen Sie es,
weniger zu trinken?
Weniger zu trinken?
Theres sagt es mir.
Sie mahnt mich. Ja, ja.
Ich möchte ihr gehorchen.
Ja, ja. Ich möchte nicht mehr.
Es reicht mir.
Einen kleinen Schluck,
dann kann ich gut einschlafen.
Das ist die Schlaftablette.
Und das ist die allgemeine Medizin.
So.
Im Brockenhaus auf dem Zollikerberg,
kochen Regula und Anny
zweimal im Jahr für die Helfer.
In diesen alltäglichen Momenten
sind sie stark.
Ich muss kurz spicken.
Bewunderst du deine Mutter,
wie sie es im Alter macht? - Ja.
Ja, das ist wirklich super.
Und zwar einfach auch weil sie
noch so viel macht.
Manchmal denke ich, wenn ich
einen solchen Terminkalender hätte -
ich wüsste nicht,
ob ich das durchstehen würde.
Sorgst du dich, ob sie es durchsteht?
Manchmal denke ich schon:
"Also jetzt ist es schon sehr viel."
"Sie müsste weniger ..."
Aber sie findet ...
(Anny) Guten morgen allerseits.
Hallo, guten Morgen.
- Guten Tag.
Grüezi wohl.
- Hoi.
Willkommen.
- Ja, danke, danke.
Hoi, Anny.
- Hoi.
Eine gute Stunde Zeit.
Für das Fleisch.  - Ja, ja.
Das kann langsam ...
Ich möchte nur,
dass der Rahm richtig ...
Nachher stelle ich wieder zurück.
Wer ist denn heute der Boss?
Ich nicht.
Gibt es bei uns Bosse?
- Was?
Gibt's bei uns Bosse?
- Aha.
Nein, eigentlich sind wir ein Team.
Manchmal regiert die eine,
manchmal die andere.
Gell, also ...
Wir spielen hier jetzt nichts vor.
Es ist vielleicht langweilig,
dass wir nie streiten.
Wann waren Sie zuletzt
nicht gleicher Meinung?
Nicht gleicher Meinung?
Ich habe sie gefragt,
warum sie zu dunklen Jupes
immer so helle Strumpfhosen trage.
Das sei doch gar nicht schön.
Da hattest du keine Freude.
Hast du das erst kürzlich gesagt?
Ja.
- Im Sommer.
Ich mag keine dunklen Strumpfhosen.
Du musst ... - Darum trug ich
keine dunklen Strumpfhosen.
Also ja,
du musst ja keine dunklen tragen,
aber nicht ganz helle.
Das stört mein ...
... modisches Empfinden.
Konntest du das annehmen?
Nein.
- Nein, ich habe es nicht gemacht.
Ich zog trotzdem an, was ich wollte.
- Das hat sie immer getan.
Mit 65.
Habt ihr auch schon mal
darüber gesprochen,
was in den nächsten Jahren
passieren wird
in Sachen Wohnen, Finanzen -
all die grossen Themen?
Das müsste man jetzt dann
in Angriff nehmen.
Wobei, sie sagt immer:
"Was passiert, wenn ich einmal
sterbe, ist mir egal."
"Ihr dürft selber entscheiden,
müsst selber schauen."
Und ... ja.
Ich glaube, das ist für sie
einfach kein Bedürfnis.
Und von dir?
- Sie war ...
... schon immer das Oberhaupt.
Das Familienoberhaupt.
Sie bestimmt.
Und von mir aus ...
Ich weiss nicht, ob ich wirklich
so bestimmend sein kann,
dass es ...
... etwas bringen
oder fruchten würde
und wir zu einem klaren Ergebnis
kommen würden.
* Lachen *
Grüezi, Herr Burkart.
Grüezi, die Spitex ist hier.
Grüezi.
- Wie geht es Ihnen?
Sind Sie noch im Bett?
Ja.
- Grüezi, Herr Burkart.
Ah ... Das Kino ist auch da.
Ja.
Ich muss etwas Wichtiges sagen.
Bevor man aufsteht,
sollte man den Kopf schütteln.
Das machen die Tiere auch.
Hilft das?
Ja, und der Lagesinn wird aktiviert.
Im Innenohr.
Jawohl. Allen einen guten Tag.
Möchten Sie nicht duschen?
- Nein.
Lieber waschen?
- Ja.
Ist es so gut?
- Ja, danke.
Hier sind die Schuhe.
So.
Willi, wie ist es mit der Spitex?
- Wie?
Wie ist es für Sie mit der Spitex?
- Ich trage kein Hörgerät.
Wie ist es für Sie,
dass die Spitex kommt?
Ah, ich bin sehr, sehr zufrieden.
Ja, mit allen.
Das ist maximal.
- Das freut uns.
Das ist auch im Preis inbegriffen.
Geht's?
- Ja.
Oh, vielen Dank, Herr Burkart.
Das ist lieb von Ihnen.
So.
Danke.
Vielen Dank.
- Ja.
Wir kommen jeden Tag
und unterstützen ihn.
Und verabreichen die Medikamente.
Schauen Sie. Soll ich sie Ihnen
in die Hand geben? - Ja.
Wir bereiten sie bei uns vor
und bringen sie jeden Tag vorbei,
damit es keine Verwechslungen gibt.
Abends und in der Nacht
nimmt er sie selber ein.
Das funktioniert gut.
- Ja, ja.
Schauen Sie, hier.
Auf Wiedersehen, Herr Burkart.
Einen schönen Tag.
Danke gleichfalls.
- Danke.
Kurz vor Weihnachten
stirbt Willis älteste Tochter Gabi.
* Melancholische Klavierklänge *
Oh, das ist schön.
Ein schöner Moment.
Ein schöner Ort.
Ja.
Sie fehlt mir.
Sie fehlt mir sehr fest.
Ich hatte sie das ganze Leben, jetzt
ist sie physisch nicht mehr hier.
Ich hätte es ihr gegönnt,
länger zu leben.
Aber jetzt ist sie im Frieden,
glaube ich.
Ja. Ja, ja.
Es ist nicht so einfach,
wenn das Kind vor einem gehen muss.
Wie?
- Wenn das Kind vor einem gehen muss.
Ja, das ist bitter.
Das habe ich mir
für sie nicht gewünscht.
* Emotionale Streichmusik *
Hast du das vorher nicht gesehen?
Geschafft.
Hans Huber, bald 96, kann nach Hause.
Erst dachte ich,
dass man das nicht mehr macht.
Die alten Menschen ...
Das ist doch verrückt.
Was möchte man denn da
noch alles machen?
War es legitim, das zu machen?
- Absolut. Ja.
Ich bin ...
In seinem Fall
war es das absolut Richtige.
Er wäre sonst verkümmert.
Freuen Sie sich,
nach Hause zu kommen?
Ich habe gemischte Gefühle.
Wieso?
- Ja ...
Ich muss nun schauen, wie es geht.
Wie mein Motor läuft.
So.
Er hat sich entschieden,
das selber zu bezahlen.
Das war ein grosser Betrag.
Er hat 50'000 selber bezahlt.
Ich muss den Rollator ...
Du kannst bei mir einhängen.
Versuchen wir es.
50'000 Fr. für die Reha in der Klinik
und den Selbstbehalt für die OP.
Es geht ja.
So, hereinspaziert.
- So.
Grüezi.
Hoi, Mama.
Vier Monate ist es her,
seit Hans Huber seine Wohnung
notfallmässig verlassen musste.
Hallo.
- Grüezi, Frau Huber.
Grüezi.
- Kommen Sie rein.
Wann kommt die Spitex am Morgen?
Das können wir zusammen besprechen.
Bevor Sie ins Spital kamen ...
... kamen wir ungefähr um 11.30 Uhr
bei Ihnen vorbei.
Ich dachte am Morgen.
Ja, für die Körperpflege?
- Und dann abends noch einmal.
Ich versuche schon,
es selber zu machen.
Aber ich sollte Hilfe haben.
Von Ihnen.
- Ja. Okay.
Die Abgrenzung
ist ein grosses Thema.
Das muss man im Auge behalten.
Gedanklich bin ich oft bei ihm.
Aber ich kann mich soweit
gut abgrenzen.
Die Spitex ist im Moment eher
für mich da als für meinen Vater,
er braucht sie weniger.
Ich habe dann die Gewissheit,
dass es ihm gut geht.
Keine Nachricht
ist eine gute Nachricht. In etwa so.
Der hält aber nicht so gut.
- Das sind die Filter.
Der Kaffee ist hier.
Das hier hält nicht so gut.
Ist das egal?
Du musst es nur richtig draufmachen.
Ja, aber ...
- Du Anfänger.
Ich habe Kaffee ...
Nervt er Sie manchmal auch?
- Ja, ja.
Ja, klar.
Ich ihn vielleicht auch.
Ja, er nervt manchmal.
Wenn er in einem Film
von früher ist
und viel davon erzählt ...
... und manchmal
auch hartnäckig ist.
Manchmal nervt es,
wenn er nichts versteht.
Ich traue dieser Sache nicht.
Jetzt kannst du ausschalten.
- So, ready.
Jetzt hat es gekocht?
Es ist schwer.
Siehst du?
- Gut.
Respekt.
Das ist technisch ...
Es funktioniert doch.
- Ja, davon bin ich überzeugt.
Wenn der Tag kommt,
an dem es zu Hause nicht mehr geht -
könnten Sie sich vorstellen,
Ihren Vater zu sich zu nehmen?
Nein. Klar nein.
Ich würde ihn nie zu mir nehmen.
Das wäre eine Überforderung,
das gehe ich nicht ein.
Diese Distanz
brauche ich tatsächlich.
Das wäre für ihn aber auch klar.
Das ist auch für ihn logisch,
dass er ins Pflegheim müsste.
Ich rufe dich morgen an.
Danke für den Beitrag.
Ja, danke auch.
- Du musstest alles ...
Ruedi vermisst dich sicher.
Mal schauen, ob er mich vermisst.
- Er soll auch mitkommen.
Ja, ja. Er kommt sicher auch einmal.
Ich rufe dich morgen an.
- Ja, ja. Ist gut.
Dann testen wir,
ob du das Telefon hörst.
Lege möglichst gleich am Morgen
als Erstes die Hörgeräte an.
Damit die Ohren funktionieren.
Das Telefon höre ich schon.
- Ja, also.
Wir schauen.
Tschüss.
Sorgen Sie sich?
Nein, ich sorge mich nicht,
aber ich bin gespannt,
wie es gehen wird.
Ich war ja immer wieder überrascht,
wie gut es gelaufen ist
und wie er das Abendessen
vorbereitet hat.
Es wird schon gehen.
Theres geht in die Ferien,
zusammen mit ihrem Partner Peter.
Wir gingen jedes Jahr.
Letztes Jahr sind wir aber
nicht in die Ferien gefahren,
weil ich für meine Schwester
hier sein wollte.
Dann kam mein Vater nach Hause.
Aber jetzt
möchte ich wieder einmal fahren.
Ihr Bruder Beni
ist zurück aus Indien.
Er arbeitet
über die Sommermonate hier.
Nun sind wieder
beide Häuschen bewohnt.
Er läuft viel besser, als damals,
als ich ihn zuletzt verlassen habe.
Und ...
Sein Gemüt ist super.
Er ist zufrieden.
Ja, er hat es gut.
So, voila.
Guten Appetit.
Tschau, Dani.
Auf Wiedersehen, Willi.
Legst du dich etwas hin?
- Ein Nickerchen, ja.
Du hast recht.
- Hast du meine neuen Zähne gesehen?
Ja, sie sehen schön aus.
Ja, wunderbar.
Tipptopp. Bis am Abend.
Ja.
Brauchst du noch was?
- Was?
- Nein, nichts.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Bei Kindern wollen wir, dass sie
möglichst bald selbstständig werden,
bei Eltern, dass sie es
so lange wie möglich bleiben.
Anny ist aktiv wie eh und je.
Im März wird sie 90.
Hier hoch
mag ich nicht mehr so viel reden.
Hans Huber treffe ich drei Monate
nach seiner Heimkehr nochmals.
Morgens kommt die Spitex vorbei.
Zweimal in der Woche wird geduscht.
Den Rest mache ich selber.
Do it yourself.
Die Menschen,
die mich für diesen Film
in ihr Leben hineinliessen,
beeindrucken mich.
Ich habe eine grosse Frage gestellt
und viele kleine Antworten erhalten.
Ein Jahr nach Drehbeginn
kann mein Sohn laufen.
Was wird er tun, falls ich dereinst
nicht mehr laufen kann?
Erwarten darf ich nichts.
Nur hoffen, dass unsere Beziehung
uns trägt und er dann da sein möchte.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Sabine Näpflin - 2020